you take incredible care of yourself
your amazing athlete you've run some
marathons many marathons have you run
I've run too okay here's a question to
have the fans must recognize you when
you're running a marathon and I would
think that would be not the time you
want to be encountering fans because
that is an intense experience to go
through
yes running that many miles and what
happens do they yell out your name are
they calling out the character's name Oh
both I would say like I'm outrun one
when I ran the New York Marathon it was
a little bit of both people were yelling
out go crazy eyes I'm like thank you and
then you know like then there was a guy
who came into the race and mind you
we're a mile 17 at this point in the
race so it's like we've been going for a
while at this point and I'm running and
starting to get like snaggletooth
and like looking crazy and this guy
comes running up to me mid race and he's
like I know who you are
I ain't gonna bother you but we're gonna
take a selfie and before insanity before
I could even say anything his camera
comes out and I was like I don't even
know the pose I probably look like I'm
like you know like crazy but he got the
camera and just disappeared and I was
like yeah people will take a selfie and
that's that I've that's a new level